PARTICULARLY COMING OFF THE
WAXING THAT COLORADO TOOK LAST
NIGH
>> Dave: IT'S A GOOD IDEA BY
TYLER TOFFOLI TO NAZEM KADRI
KIND OF LOST POSSESSION, GOT IT
BACK, AND GIRARD FE AND MONTREA
BACK IN TION IS DARCY KUEMPER DD
TAKE A SHOT UP HIGH YESTERDAY  G
>> Dave: STRONG SHIFT FOR
CHRISTIAN DVORAK
IN, ONE-TIMER.SAVE.
>> Dave: FIRST SUSTAINED ZONE
TIME THAT COLORADO HAS HAD, THE
NICHUSHKIN LI
THAT HIT CHIAROT.T.
ENTIRE MONTREAL GROUP WITH THE
ICING, SO THAT'S BEN CHIARARIN.
JOHNSON NUMBER THREE AND PLAY
MacKINNON SENDS IT CROSS ICE,
WRIST SHOT UP HIGH, REBOPICKS
NICHUSHKIN BELOW THE GOAL LINE,
FINAL MINUTE BELL CENTRE, FIRST.
HE IS RIGHT SQUARED TO THIS  VA
JOHNSON, SLAP SHOT HE MISSED.
GOES WIDE AS THE MONTREAL
CANADIENSNS
IN.
>> Dave: WHAT A PASS FROM
JONATHANT THERE ON THE
POWERPLAY UNIT AS O'CONNOR USING
HIS SPEED AND TAKES IT AWAY.HAT
BACKHAND SIDE, HE'S IN TROUBLE
RIGHT AWAY.
ND A
TOUGH ONE, HE GIVES IT AWAY A
>> Dave: HE SEES THE PLAY, JEFF.
CHIAROT GETS IT BACK AT THE
LINE, WRIST SHOT, , .
LITTLE TWIRL OF THE STICK. CHIP.
GIRARD I THINK IT'S L
>> Bryan:
WRONG...
TIPS, SIDE OF THE NET, STILL
LOOSE IN THE CREASE, SCORES!
TO CLEAR IT AND JUST FALLS
>> Dave: HE PLAYED TWO FULL
YEARS AGAIN
LANDESKOG.
BACK TO MAKAR AS THEY WORK I I
T
>> Dave: MIKKO